i think iceland is actually so out of
all the countries
iceland has the largest number of grand
masters per capita
because population is what like just
over 300 000
and they have i think they have close to
a dozen gm's
okay new game what country is this
peru never been to peru
peru also has like um at least a few
gm's
okay um do i play a stafford let's play
a stafford
everyone's playing e4 today right
i guess i had i had the 1d4 game
okay stafford accepted
opponent thinking this is always this is
very welcoming
so my opponent probably has not seen
nerditsky's video
oh but maybe saw it this is what
narediski recommended
ah okay
don't hurt me
it's nice that they're thinking ah
they're playing the best line though
i mean i'm kind of prepared for this
line like this is kind of the worst case
scenario
and white knows this exact move order
uh bishop g5 i can play this actually i
don't think bishop g5 is the best move i
think knight t2 is the best move
it's still not great for me
um there's tricks this is still an idea
for a moment i was thinking this is this
but there's bishop e3 in the end
and queen c5 i want to play queen c5
it doesn't quite work though if i play
knight here there is this move
knight c4 also coming man
okay so a point is
is punishing the stafford let's um yeah
let's be consistent with my plans at
least
i'll pretend that i know what i'm doing
all white needs to do is castle and then
the game can end
so what are the candidate moves bishop
h4 or
or d4 really
so i'm preparing after d4 to play queen
g6 oh there's also that
and this is maybe consideration let's
take with pawn
oh both pawns are hanging
but i can't i can't take either of them
i could move knight c4
um
okay still down the pawn
but it's um it's actually not so bad i
have both
flank files and i have a pawn cube
and don't mess with a pawn cube
bishop e6 i guess
so there's an idea of this and this or
this and this
wow castling is so brave
i commanded my opponent's bravery but it
might also just be
oh that's a good move though
i thought i was going to be attacking
opponent wants to destroy my pawn cube
so i want to do this there's a
calculation rook h5
takes queen h7 queen f4 um
so maybe i should just play this
immediately defend this and then prepare
this in this
i mean i want to um i want to build the
gun
this uh the triple battery on the the
half open h file
let's go
b3 was maybe a slow move
hmm opponent wants to play queen g3
and build a diagonal gun
rook h3 is rk3 is just bad
what to do here
man white's so solid
can i play
[Music]
maybe f6
kind of slow playing it so the idea is
to play this and this and defend c7
and also later play g5 to prevent uh
white from getting these two squares for
the queen and bishop
play this first and it's going to be a
time scramble
okay so now i'm the yeah so queen g3 g5
is such a nice move
attacks the bishop and defends the pawn
and removes the bishop from defending h2
wait can i take that
let's start with this i'm not sure
ah i'm allowing queen g3 now
i can't defend c7
i have this move okay it's getting crazy
idea g5 and i don't know what's
happening
i sacked a piece but i'm maybe winning
h2
the bishop is kind of trapped oh but
there's this move
but then f5 what's happening
we're trading my pawn cube survives
somehow
in win h2 now threatening this and
maybe winning the rook
that's winning because it's a mate
threat and a skewer threat let's go
wow what a weird game don't mess with
the pawn cube
the pawn cube was pretty irrelevant to
the whole like king side
[Music]
that was a fun game though
yeah this is why this hurt is maybe a
little bit risky
opponent played really well in the
opening
like this is this is exactly what
neridsky recommended
but i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
bishop g5 or knight d2 is just
good for white
thanks tagi if this goes on youtube
i say hi to tagi say hi to homeless
pluto
and everyone else in the chat
did rook e8 save the position in the end
oh rookie 8 oh rookie 8 is
is a saving move
oh i didn't even realize that that's a
good point
this is a great puzzle white to move and
survive this is the only saving move
well it's probably winning in the final
position
[Music]
or maybe i don't know maybe not because
i still have the pawn cube
but takes takes and it's a rook ending
five pawns versus six pawns
yeah the game would go on
oh it's just equal yeah rookie only only
moved to i guess equalize
wow so if you're watching in the future
on youtube
let me know in the comments if you saw
rookie 8
well the clutch move i just assumed like
because the whole focus is like on the
main threat
and the skewer on the first rank
it's a whole concept of misdirection
you're so focused on like this area you
forget about counter play
okay oh look done
for the win saw rookie 8 and there's
also a pleb
wow all done